no one knows what curves life will throw
it
but if a driver has the courage to
create his own conditions and the rain
is simply rain
book was so beloved I just gobbled it up
and cried my face off Milo has been in a
part of his career where he's making
everyone cry you know how how cry ye are
we getting Oh many boxes of tissues well
I brought this handkerchief that Milo
gave to me during the table read in
Vancouver last year last spring and I
soaked that I soaked it and I washed it
and I've had it ever since and I brought
it with me because it's gonna probably
happen again
but that's the big that's that's when I
know I'm having a good time this is why
I go to the movies I want to feel god
it's the best thing this is a family
film Finn can go see it did he like
being on Sat um
Finn wasn't on set that was the one
stipulation
he's in my he's in my writer in my
contract I have like very few things I
think it was a once it was a piano and
Finn and now it's just been and he
wasn't allowed on set for this because
of the working dogs because of Parker
and Butler and orbit and all the dogs we
had playing Enzo I couldn't and I I
didn't want to yeah they were working
and so he stayed in my trailer and
walked around he had it I mean he he was
fine and I'm not saying I love the cover
of Taylor Swift mean will there be a
record have you has she reached out to
yet to be in the squad no uh what do you
think no I
that was Ashley parks idea actually like
taking it back to her first album this
is so smart and like making the mean
girl tie it was really fun we did three
nights in a row and it got better better
it actually for the first time ever I
had zero stage fright so now I feel like
maybe I can do a Broadway show where I
actually sang at least an album or a
duet would taste Swizzle no I mean I
would do do I would tastes whiz but I
wouldn't release now but because that
means you have to go on the road and I
don't want to go on the road
[Music]